hello listeners of this podcast in
keeping with us generally always being
behind schedule this podcast was
recorded before the last weekend which
was a very bad one so if you're
wondering why we don't reference the
shootings in Orlando that's why I
imagine they will come up in the next
episode thank you for listening and
dftba hello and welcome to dear Hank and
John or is that pretty good Dear John
and Hank it's a County podcast where me
and my brother John we answer your
questions we give you dubious advice and
we bring you all the week's news from
both Mars and AFC Wimbledon a third tier
English soccer club not tired of hearing
that Hank I believe it I got to update
the description of dear Hank and John
and I'm not entirely sure how to do it
right because it says we talk about a
fourth tier English soccer team but we
don't anymore it's almost as if there
was a planet discovered between Earth
and Mars we have to edit the podcast as
well but it turns out that AFC Wimbledon
much more change than Mars no offense to
Mars ah yeah no agreed there is kind of
a planet between Mars and Jupiter but
that's not gonna help anything how are
you doing John I am doing well I'm
having a little bit of an existential
crisis as a result of a book I'm reading
that was recommended to me by our father
called sapiens are you familiar with
this book Hank I am I just received it
in the mail from our father it's a great
really interesting history book but I
cannot in good faith recommend it
because it has sent me into an absolute
spiral of fear and loathing fear and
life as Robert Penn Warren once famously
wrote that I'm a bubble on the tide of
empire more than ever I feel that I am
not making any of the choices that are
supposedly mine but instead am just you
know a tiny dot in a much larger
pointillist painting that is being
shaped by forces far far larger than
myself
it's interesting to me that that's not
how you felt previously well I have
little moments where I feel like I have
something approaching proper free will
but no longer that's that's ended yeah I
yeah actually we just recorded an
episode of crash course philosophy on
free will and
in general the the philosophical
agreement is that we don't we just don't
there's it's very difficult to once
you've once you start down that rabbit
hole to come to a conclusion that
indicates that that we actually have any
choice in the matter however it feels
like we do and that's the important
thing I'm not sure that is the important
thing actually I feel no you know as
I've gotten it's interesting because as
I've gotten older I find myself less and
less convinced by the acts of my
so-called volition and I feel more and
more like you know people don't wield
power so much as power wields people oh
my well that's not really what I was
talking about but maybe we should have a
poem before we just start talking about
existentialism for the entire episode
all right this is another haiku from
Richard Wright I'm a huge Richard Wright
fan and he's written a lot of good
haikus over the years you moths must
leave now I am turning out the light and
going to sleep alright so the real you
love that one Hank because it's short
hold on let me crack open a delicious
diet alright oh my goodness is there a
better sound I thought we were gonna
stop with the dr. pepper stuff why would
we stop with it it's delicious I love I
love drinking diet dr. pepper okay I see
I see
well you just continue with the loving
dr. pepper but we won't mention whether
or not we would like dr. pepper to
sponsor no I don't want dr. pepper just
I don't actually want diet dr. pepper to
sponsor us and now that diet dr. pepper
follows me on Twitter I feel that we've
kind of flown too close to the Sun on
this one and I'm getting very anxious
the diet dr. pepper might actually offer
me money and then I would have to turn
them down because my stupid brother
doesn't allow me to take sponsorships so
yeah uh-huh yeah yeah so we have to turn
off the light so that the moth that is
diet dr. pepper will go home that is
correct we have got to turn off those
lights to keep those diet dr. pepper
moths from floating about dear Hank and
John all right John I have a question
that I wasn't actually intending to ask
but it became so apropos while we were
having this conversation to begin of the
podcast it's from Ellen who asks dear
Hank and John Elon Musk said in an
interview that we are probably all
simulations of people rather than
actual people I feel weird when I think
about this does this mean that my
choices matter less because they aren't
real or does it mean that my choices
matter more because they matter not only
to me but to whatever entity is
observing / experiencing what I do do
you have any advice for how to feel
about possibly being a simulation of the
person that I thought that I was well I
wouldn't worry too much about it is my
advice though Jonna is worrying quite a
lot about it right now due to a book
he's reading it's it's hard not to worry
about the problem is that it's just not
particularly useful to worry about Hank
are you familiar with the turtles all
the way down thing yes no I think you've
talked about the turtles all the way
down on this very podcast I for me it's
just a it for me the question of whether
we are a simulation is a Turtles all the
way down type of issue it is it is not
something that can lead to productive
lines of thought and I'm not sure as
like I'm I'm not sure that it's worth
thinking about things we can't fix yeah
we we just we just recorded an episode
of crash course philosophy about this
topic it has not it has not come out yet
but it will so I suggest that you go
watch crash course philosophy where we
taught we'll talk about determinism and
freewill and whether Free Will exists
and all of the ways in which we have
made those arguments over the years in
some ways it doesn't even matter whether
or not it's a simulation because even if
it weren't there are there are you know
logical trains that you can follow that
will lead you to the the realization
that just based on how the Big Bang
happened today was inevitable that's a
very difficult thing to come to terms
with I do feel like I'm making choices
all the time you know many of the things
that I do are not are clearly not
choices but many of the things that I do
are and I do feel as if I make those
choices and I think that the way that we
experience the world is in many ways the
most important thing rather than the way
the world actually is and I don't I
don't you know I don't know that
everybody's gonna agree with me on that
but that
is what I have come to believe done yeah
I mean there's different kinds of
realness right I mean there's the
realness of you know there's the
realness for instance of the theory of
relativity like we know that these laws
govern the the natural world and then
there's the realness of like the limited
liability corporation or laws against
murder like those things are constructed
but they are also quite real you know
yeah they're real because we all believe
in them together but that doesn't mean
that they're not real and I think we
have to be very careful about the things
that we believe in together the the
things that we choose to make real by
force of our believing in them but I
think we will always have those things
whether they're gods or corporations or
laws against murder we have to have
those kind of shared beliefs those are
the things that I'm worried about I
guess if we collectively decided that we
were living inside of a simulation that
would have a big impact on the human
story but I don't think that's a like a
shared belief and I don't think it would
necessarily be a very helpful one yeah I
kind of feel a little bit like Elon Musk
is just just making the gamble and
saying like I'm gonna go ahead and say
that we live in a simulation potentially
we do and if we do maybe the person
who's watching can be like oh Elon Musk
he does so many interesting things in my
simulation including realizing that he's
in what a great guy yeah that makes you
I must feel good about himself right
it's like Pascal's wager right it's at
this Elon Musk's wager he's betting that
we're in a simulation and he just really
impressed somebody there's some 11 year
old boy in some kind of super universe
who's just like oh man one of them
finally figured me out all right John
yet another question for me not really
I'm still stuck inside of this
existential loop that I can't get out of
the whole problem with obsessive
thinking Hank is that it takes the form
of these like ever tightening spirals
from which there is no freedom until
suddenly it does just go away and you're
like huh that was weird anyway yeah I
have a question this question okay Bell
who writes Dear John and Hank my brother
makes me listen to your podcast on the
way to school every day and although I
try very hard not to I started to like
it though my brother claims I am now a
nerdfighter I refuse to accept a title I
do not understand do nerdfighters fight
nerds fight for the term nerds or are
they nerds that fight my brother says he
thinks nerds that fight but fight what
you can't fight without having something
to fight that's just really bad / weird
dancing just a great observation Bella
that if you're fighting without having
something or someone to fight really
you're just dancing and well I don't
know that it's necessarily bad weird
dancing maybe you're a really good know
person fight dancer yeah it could be it
could be excellent dancing the point is
that it is not fighting it's dancing she
makes a good point there well I think
that it's possible that John and I are
you know members of the community of
nerdfighters and all we are in fact
doing is bad / weird dancing about
things I actually be it might be a
really astute insight yes but to answer
your question Bella the idea is that
nerdfighters fight for nerds in the same
way that freedom fighters ostensibly
fight for freedom and as far as being a
nerdfighter we've always said that if
you think you might be a nerdfighter you
probably are one there's no like
initiation right or anything it's just
one identity among many that you choose
for yourself for the time that you
consider yourself to be that and we
would welcome you as a nerdfighter but
we also welcome if you don't consider
yourself a nerdfighter yeah you could
just be a fan of the pod yeah the only
requirement is that you do have to fight
but not fight against anyone so you do
have to do the dance fighting that is
that is a technical requirement of
joining our club right right of even if
being a listener of the podcast I expect
that all of you are doing we are dance
fighting right now yeah I know wherever
you are two things that you need to know
first oh my god it's burning second you
better be dance fighting right now I'm
doing it I'm doing drinking my tie Dr
Pepper and dance fighting in front of
the microphone I am likewise dance
fighting
alright egg should we move on to another
question I don't even believe you by the
way your your dancing is - my dancing is
very
you know it's something I do primarily
from the elbow to the fingertip your
dancing is a full-body thing so there's
no way you could be doing an in front of
a microphone
oh I but I can keep excellent body
isolations so I can keep my head
perfectly still while moving my the rest
of my body vigorously which is what I'm
doing right now I mean I would love to
see that dance in real life the head
still body vigorously moving dance all
right this question is from Megan she
asks dear Hank and John I'm pretty new
to the podcast but a long-term fan of
the vlogbrothers so I have been binging
on all the old episodes to catch up I
have a long term history of talking
nonsense in my sleep my boyfriend
recently told me that I have been
talking about Mars in my sleep and I
attribute that to the pod do you have
any dubious advice for how to stop
talking in my sleep no I do not why
would I make you stop this sounds great
no I talking in your sleep is a
dangerous dangerous business Hank
because you could say something that's
true and secret huh so you definitely
don't want to talk in your sleep
unfortunately I know of no way to
prevent yourself from talking in your
sleep except to take ambien which does
seem to work at least for me but not a
great long-term solution I I think I
think that as long as you're just
talking about Mars in your sleep there's
no problem so make sure that you just
continue to talk just about Mars the
only way you can do that is to think a
lot about Mars which is you know
obviously a wonderful thing to do anyway
and then have have your boyfriend take
notes on the things that you're saying
about Mars and send them to us we'd be
interested to hear that I think we have
another question this one is from Robin
who writes
Dear John and Hank my name is Robin stop
trying to be Ryan Robin my name is Robin
and I'm the germ conscious mother of a
two-year-old who absolutely loves going
to the library and checking out stacks
of books as we sit and read through the
books each week I can't help but wonder
if they are actually virus and bacteria
infested things that I'm bringing into
my home and allowing my daughter to
touch and enjoy am I being paranoid or
other grimy kids leaving their germs on
the books were checking out great
question Robin and way to get to an
issue that's right at the heart of my
personal experience with the world well
you aren't being paranoid Robin those
books are indeed covered
in viruses in bacteria the good news is
cell is everything else and you're fine
yeah the nice thing about books is that
at least you're learning something while
getting sick instead of just getting
sick well let's say let's say that the
world is alive with a thin film of
beautiful and invisible organisms and
they almost never kill you
so that's good right know one thing I
would say about this actually is there
is a study done recently that a pretty
pretty robust study that followed kids
who went to daycare starting at 12 weeks
of age and kids who stayed home it
followed them through primary school and
one of the findings was that kids who go
to daycare do get sick more often during
the preschool years than kids who stay
home either with their parents or with a
nanny however over the course of the
entirety of the study to the end of
primary school the kids got sick an
approximately equal amount because the
kids who went to because the kids who
stay at home just got sick more in
elementary school so in the end I don't
think there is any way you know wash
your hands obviously encourage your kids
to wash their hands use hand sanitizer
if you if you want to but in the end
there's no way to prevent your kids from
getting colds and flus it's just part of
growing up and it's actually an
important part of being it yes we have
we have powerful and amazing immune
systems if you want to learn about those
you can watch crash course biology oh my
god a hank is with the Schilling today I
wonder where you can get high-quality
activewear Hank maybe at dftba.com it's
possible dftba.com well for all of your
high-quality activewear needs oh man I
don't even want to I don't even want to
do the podcast with you if you're gonna
be a seller all right let's move on then
I apologize deep deep apologies we have
another question this one's from Ben who
asks dear Hank and John my name is Ben
and I been and having a difficult time
determining whether or not the amount of
paper towels given to me by the paper
towel dispenser in bathrooms is enough
to fully dry my moistened hands please
reply by podcast
well first off Ben I'm gonna say the
same thing to you that I said to Robin
stop trying
B Ryan there's only one Ryan and his
name is Ryan that's right
second as an owner of a building I was
surprised to discover that the the the
owner of the building determines how
much paper towel comes out of the paper
towel dispenser there's a setting on it
that lets you do that and you could be
like tiny amount or huge big sheet you
can usually stop it
if you're like hey that's enough paper
towel just by ripping it off and the
machine will be like okay you got enough
but sometimes they do like these like
tiny little sheets that I'm like okay
yeah I kind of need more than that
there's a great video on the internet
about how to properly dry your hands
yeah what's your Smith like like fast
like it turns out that up drying your
hands is a really important partner for
washing your hands because wet hands us
have more bacteria that stick to them so
it's best to dry them as quickly as
possible after washing them and and the
most efficient way to do it
turns out to be too quick like shake
them dry like 12 times and that gets off
like the vast majority of the water and
then and then use a small piece of paper
towel folded over and when you fold it
over this increases a capillary action
that will pull blower water off of your
hands more quickly and there's a video
that you can watch it's quite short
about that that yeah it's a TED talk
actually it's about four minutes and 30
seconds long and it's this brilliant guy
Joe Smith who tells you how to use
exactly one paper towel while getting
your hands entirely dry and of all the
videos I've spent four minutes and 30
seconds watching it is the one that
probably has had the biggest impact on
my life because ever since then I have
only used one paper towel and I've
gotten my hands completely dry and it's
a game change it is it is I'm not gonna
disagree with you John uh you know we're
gonna put the video up on the patreon so
everybody can check it out
patreon.com/scishow apologize for the
shilling but you don't have to give to
the video you can just go to
patreon.com/scishow pijn open to the
public's ah you got another question for
us it's your turn
speaking of bathroom sink we have a
question from Emma who writes Dear John
and Hank if someone knocks on the
bathroom door what is the least awkward
way to let him know
bathroom is occupied this is a great
question because it's usually question
because we have all been in the
situation where like somebody knocks on
the door and then you don't know what to
say sometimes I say I made it here yeah
sometimes I inexplicably speak Spanish
and say ocupado you know what I almost I
almost always say and this is awful I
almost always say just a sec and then
it's like but no which might be a false
promise I mean you need to there are
times when when just a sec is
functionally almost always as soon as I
say just a sec I'm like in my head I'm
like Who am I kidding
it is not going to be just a sec ha ha
ha ha it is going to be many sacks and
yeah and then I but then you can't say
that you can't be like just a sec by
which I mean probably about 4 minutes so
Hank in the same way that we have
established a rule for proper armrest
usage in movie theaters and on airplanes
I think this is the moment you know we
have a chance to really affect culture
here I may not believe I may not believe
in free will but I do believe that a
group of committed people working
together can come up with one word or
phrase to express I am in this stall of
the bathroom that you are attempting to
occupy yeah I mean really all all you
have to say is anything they know that
you're there so you could just be like
ah yeah but you don't want to say that
because then people will be like well
that was an odd encounter right you want
to have something where it's just a kind
of a universal okay I got it it you want
to have basically you want to have ah
that's a socially acceptable phrase
that's why I'm quite fond of ocupada but
what if what if what if you want to
convey more information than that if you
like you want to if if you do if you are
in fact just washing up and you're about
to be out you could just you couldn't
say just a sec but if it's gonna be a
while you could be like four minutes or
oh just it'll be I'll be in here for a
bit longer I think four minutes is a
terrible idea I think for I I still
like ocupado because I think it's I
think it's I think it's like a universal
language everybody knows what ocupado
means oh man if only like why don't all
bathroom doors have those locks that
when you lock them it shows whether
there's somebody in there it's a
physical mechanism that's like occupied
and it's done it's probably an expense
issue
so to summarize em Hank and I are
struggling between two competing ways of
saying I am inside of this bathroom one
is to shout ocupado the other is to
shout for minutes or or two minutes or
eight minutes or whatever you think is
appropriate what I like about the not
shouting a number of minutes is that
then you aren't making a potentially
false promise right all I can say for
sure in this messed-up crazy world is
that right now I am in the bathroom I
have no real way of knowing if I'm gonna
be in there forever
frankly once you once you read sapience
I'll agree with me I might be in the
bathroom for 30 seconds I might very
well die inside of it so I feel like
saying
ocupado is just a way of saying like I
am describing the current situation
right okay I I can get behind ocupado
unless I hear a better unless I hear
better from someone you can always send
us some tweets at Hank green or John
Green with the hashtag dear Hank and
John if you have a better suggestion
than ocupado all right we've got another
question this one's from Scott Scott
asks dear Hank and John I have had a
nagging fear about money lately
purchasing anything has left me feeling
stressed out even though I'm out of
college have good income and graciously
I'm not in crippling debt and I feel
like I'm becoming obsessed with saving
money
maybe it's my unconscious desire to fund
at the wimbledon stadium for a fear that
i won't have enough money to survive the
apocalypse which is very irrational
since the currency probably won't be
accepted then how can I learn to relax
and not let my spending be a source of
anxiety this is an interesting question
Hank because I think most of us struggle
more with saving than with spending you
know I think it's
really really important to save money
especially when you're young I really
believe that even if you don't have a
lot of income if you can save even very
small amounts of money in your 20s it
makes a massive massive difference much
later in your life especially after
retirement but there are people who
begin to treat savings sort of
obsessively and become very anxious
about trying to save more and more and
more money and just like anything it's
never enough um I don't have a great
solution for this I think that it's
better than the spending problem but I
don't want to minimize it because I
think it is still a problem yeah I
actually this is something that I
struggle with it is a it's it's less now
but I'd like anytime I you know as a
younger person when I was making a
significant purchase I would get sweaty
my chest would clinch up especially
right afterward and I would feel like
like who's like you know we'll make a
significant amount of anxiety which is
pretty unusual for me but this is a
thing that I have experienced anxiety
about I still do though generally with
business spending then with personal
spending now and and and it it is so so
that is it's a Zen anxiety and things
like that tend to get better with
experience of course don't run out and
like have a lot of spending experiences
just to get over your anxiety because
that could have other negative
consequences but my my strategy and this
is just my strategy among many
strategies is to is to think about it
economically and in a in sort of a
analytical businessí way of the return
on the investment of the thing that I'm
spending and this is called RLI analysis
it's a thing that you do in business so
if I'm if I'm getting a new computer I I
have always had this feeling when
getting new computers even now I let
them like ah but if I think about like
okay my current computer is wasting my
time because it is broken it is slow and
and fixing it would take a lot of my
time getting a new one is the value that
I am spending money on is the time that
it's going to free up so the value when
buying a new car like what's the value
there the value when I'm getting
gasoline what's the value there getting
car insurance or getting health
insurance like under like or buying
healthier food what's like like the
value of being a healthier person is
worth the money that I'm spending
understanding the value transaction
that's happening helps me get over this
this hurdle of like always having felt
weird about money and about spending
money and always knowing that like that
is a like it is a thing that you can't
undo and it is there's money that you
can't get back which is cut for me often
the source of the anxiety I think also
probably just a weird relationship that
I have with money for lots of different
reasons
the other thing you can do Hank is that
I would suggest is that you can have a
brother who steals your money and spends
it then you know I feel like that's been
useful for you over the years really
starting when I was about 14 and Hank
was 11 I noticed that Hank had hundreds
and hundreds of dollars that he'd saved
over the years from never having spent
any money and I liked spending money so
I didn't have any money and I thought
well that's not fair that Hank has you
know $400 that he's rolled up into these
these tiny tight bills that he's then
stuffed inside of his soccer
participation trophies and I just
remember thinking it's just it's just
not fair you know that Hank has all of
this money and that I have none and I
would complain to my parents about it
and they would be like but you we gave
you the same amount of money it's just
that you spent it and Hank saved it and
I was like right right I understand that
but the point is that he now has money
and I now don't like we can't do
anything about what happened in the past
the current situation is that there is
this extreme unfairness of Hank having
hundreds of dollars stuffed into soccer
participation trophies that he has no
there is no way that Hank is ever going
to spend any of that money I mean the
truth is Hank still hasn't spent that
money I bow to his childhood soccer
trophies and you unscrew them you'll
find him out of ten dollar bills wadded
up in there
and and so I started spending Hanks
money and let me tell you it felt great
it wasn't even really stealing because
again it was a question of it being our
money that Hank had just failed to spend
so what what John is saying is it's
important to note that you can't take it
with you sometimes you can't even take
it with you to middle school well okay
all of that noted it when I was in
college one summer you decided that I
didn't need my baseball cards anymore
and you sold them all on eBay uh well
you did just leave them home yeah but
you sold them on eBay and then you saved
the money and never gave it to me so I
think we're you I don't remember that I
don't know I don't know if that's the
thing that how that is absolutely a
thing that happened that is 100% of me
we can call mom and dad if you want but
that is 100% a thing that happened you
sold my baseball cards just as surely as
Tuggle is not dead another question then
this one's from Arie who asks dear Hank
and John do you have any dubious advice
on how to enjoy physical activity I've
been going to the gym more lately but
the thing is I hate it I listen to your
podcast helps pass the time but it's
still not enough to make it remotely
enjoyable how can I make exercising more
fun well re podcasts are my only trick
so John
hate to be honest I don't even find
podcasts adequately distracting because
there's a lot of dead air and podcast
when I can hear my labored breathing and
during that time I become aware that I'm
inside of a you know a slowly decaying
vessel and that's very distressing to me
so I usually just listen to music all I
can say is that in my mind at least the
benefits of exercise are back-ended like
the benefits of exercise mostly come you
know ten or twelve or sixteen weeks into
the process and for me at least once
that happens it gets way more fun but
you've got to put in all of that time
before it happens I I have also heard
people who are you know experts in this
saying things like you have to trick
yourself as if you are a dog so give
yourself rewards for doing a thing that
you don't like doing
and then you will start to like them and
not really know why so do your best to
make going to the gym some kind of
positive experience and I do not know
how to do that but you know if you give
yourself some kind of chew toy or
playtime or doggie biscuit that makes
that will make it feel as if it is a
positive thing in your life I don't I
don't know how to actually do that that
is a piece of advice I've heard from
other people and not been able to
implement in my own life so I've got
another question if that's okay with you
John no no it's not okay because I would
just like to say a word from our
sponsors today's podcast is brought to
you by tricking yourself like a dog
tricking yourself like you would a dog
I don't really drinking tricking
yourself like you would a dog the
fastest way to enjoy exercise this
podcast is also brought to you by weird
/ bad dance fighting weird / bad dance
fighting it's a it's the only thing that
you're allowed to do while you listen to
your Hank and John and it's also
probably exercise cut kind of so good
just been such a funny podcast we should
do this okay now you can get to your
other question all right this one's from
Nina who asks dear Hank and John I
recently started thinking about how we
as humans never stop growing and
changing every year every decade every
century we surpass unimaginable
milestones that are simply incredible to
witness what makes me sad though is that
I will know what existed before me but I
will never truly know what will exist
after me I think of how awestruck Jane
Austen would have been if had she had
had a chance to look into the world
where the world is today where Mahatma
Gandhi or Isaac Newton or anyone else
how do I overcome or manage this
gloominess caused but the by the unknown
/ unknowable I would I would say we
actually don't know that much about the
past you know like there's 2.5 million
years of hominid history and we only
know anything about like the last 10,000
years of it and we only know much about
like the last three or four hundred
years of it and if you look outside the
the realm of the like most noted or for
famous people the people who had access
to the
the kind of power to tell their own
stories we really only know the history
of like the last hundred fifty two
hundred years at the most so I actually
think that we're living in a kind of on
a weird island where we don't know very
much about what human life was like on a
day to day basis before relatively
recently and of course we know nothing
about what it will look like in the
future but we don't know what
hunter-gatherers were like we don't know
much about what life was like in early
agriculturalists communities I would say
that I would I would say that ultimately
we kind of only know ourselves yeah I I
think that this is what us what are the
sad things about death John and and not
just on a macro scale but on on a micro
scale you know when you die if you die
in the sort of correct order that the
sad thing will be that you will never
get to see you know who your
grandchildren fall in love with and what
they become and when who you know like
you lose you don't get to find out all
the things about the people that you
love that you wish you could find out it
just it ends and it's a super bummer and
the fact that you're thinking about this
naina on a you know a humanity wide
scale means that you believe in humanity
and you have a lot of interest in in
faith in humanity and that's good and
this is a side effect of that feeling of
you know appreciating all of the things
that humans have come together to create
over the years that have made your life
better and and and appreciating that and
not and knowing that there will be
things that will come after that you
won't know about that it says it's a
symptom of you know your appreciation
for the work of other people and and a
symptom of the fact that we're all going
to die and it's a bit of a bummer
there's not really much to do about it
though except to recognize that it comes
mostly from good places it's a bit of a
bummer but on the other hand to me at
least there's something beautiful about
the fact that we're all sort of
collaborators in this massive sprawling
story and that we're going to be in the
middle of it
I don't want to be at the end of the
human story you know like I don't want
my life nono yeah like that'll last what
the human life I want to be in the
middle of the story and I wanted
try to you know in my infinitesimal way
shape the story so that it makes it more
possible for it to go on longer and
better for as many people as possible so
in a way it's good news I have a really
quick question from Ray who asks dear
Hank and John in the past John you have
okayed two tattoos inspired by your book
so long as they are not somebody's first
tattoo Hank do you have a similar
request for tattoos inspired by the
things that you create I'm getting a
Hank ler fish tattoo next month and I
want to know your thoughts love from
your brother with the last name of
another color Ray Brown uh yeah go it's
your body man do whatever you want
that's how I feel I think that's great
the only reason I'm concerned about
people getting their first tattoo with a
quote from my books or something is I
just worry that later they'll regret it
but if it's a second tattoo I somehow
feel that I've been absolved but you're
right it's not my body so why am I
trying to intervene indeed Adam writes
Dear John and Hank if nothing sticks to
Teflon how do they get Teflon to stick
to a pan all right I'm not I'm gonna do
this and not I assume that John doesn't
have much to say on the subject
correct all right Teflon is a chemical
it's actually it's a brand name for a
chemical and that chemical it's
basically a carbon chain with so every
carbon is bonded to two other carbons
that makes the chain and then on you
know sort of the top and bottom of the
chain it's bonded to fluorine and
fluorines are loved to bond to stuff and
carbon also loves to bond to stuff so
those that that bond becomes very strong
those electrons becomes very sort of
occupied with that bond and that they
don't interact with the rest of the
world at all they hate the rest of the
world they're super happy and never want
to talk to anything which is why nothing
sticks to it so you have that problem
then if if it doesn't want to stick to
anything how do you make it stick to the
pan they do chemistry on it so once you
make this sort of Teflon coating it will
have sides it will have a top and a
bottom side the top side is what's going
to be facing the world so you want that
to remain all Teflon II the bottom side
you do chemistry on it to make those
fluorines go away and when you do that
it actually gets super sticky because
suddenly those car
want to bond to stuff so you knock those
fluorines off of the bottom layer of the
Teflon you do that either with like
they're really don't want to get knocked
off so you have to do pretty intense
chemistry you either like bombard it
with high-energy plasma or like really
strong reducing agents and then those
fluorines go away and the carbons want a
bond to something else and they bond to
whatever the pain is made of and that's
how that works thank you for the science
question it's been a while since I got
to talk about science on the pond I
don't know why more science questions
people I don't actually know if we need
more science questions that was
interesting but I kept zoning in and out
the way I almost like I don't know it
was intense Hank it was intense for me
well you know I it's it's just you know
Teflon is just another example of the
tiny the tiny changes that we make in
our world that make life better for
everybody and how to make Teflon stick
to a pan they had to figure that out and
who figured that out yeah I don't know
mr. toeffler
probably not and somebody somebody who
mattered to the world well I think it's
great I think it's beautiful Hank
is there any news from Mars this week Oh
is there ever
there's always news from Mars John it's
just I have to pick which which bit to
cover so this week 40 people have been
selected from over 200,000 applicants to
be finalists in the quest to die on Mars
Mars one is a ambitious and probably
impossible plan to send people on a
one-way trip to Mars and they will
eventually from that pool of 40 people
select 26 people that they want to send
sort of four people at a time and it's
it's a Mars one is one of several
existing plans right now to get humans
on the surface of Mars in my opinion if
you lined
those those projects out from most to
least likely Mars one would be at the
bottom of the list but but it's still
interesting still a thing that they're
trying to do and they want to build a
permanent colony on Mars so it would be
a one-way trip and hopefully those
people would live their natural
lifespans on Mars and not get killed by
Mars which is pretty likely but they
live there but not
lesbians on Mars and even maybe have
children on Mars and raise generations
on Mars and start the process of having
there be a sort of second second
humanity out there and they plan to
partially fund this effort with a
reality TV show and they want to use
SpaceX's Falcon heavy rocket to get to
the Red Planet so they're not like
developing any of their own technology
they're just trying to figure out how to
fund it which I just I don't understand
how it's going to work but it is
interesting to me and they do have these
people who have you know are talking
about like why they are people who you
know like they see this as a thing that
they want to do with their lives and I
find that interesting and cool to hear
this people talk about it it's not a
choice that I would make but it is
interesting to hear people talk about it
and of course SpaceX which is making the
Falcon Heavy rough rocket has its own
plans or Elon Musk at least does to send
humans to Mars and actually get them
back but I'm not gonna judge
let's send people to Mars I'm into that
let's let's investigate possibilities I
I myself would want to die on earth I
know John I know but not introduce Phil
I just want it to be clear in case like
in case I happen to not die on earth I
just want the world to know that was not
my wish all right Hank the news from AFC
Wimbledon is that as you know AFC
Wimbledon is now a third tier English
soccer team this is both an opportunity
in that we find ourselves in the third
tier and a massive problem in that you
know we would like to stay there and AFC
Wimbledon which used to have the
smallest Stadium in league to now has
the smallest Stadium in League One as a
result Wimbledon fans are raising money
for the playing budget through the we
are Wimbledon fund you can you can learn
more about it at we are Wimbledon
fun.com
basically it's a trust that's set up to
increase the playing budget it's been
working for several years but because
the club is owned entirely by its fans
money for the playing budget and stuff
has to come primarily from its fans so
they've been raising money and in other
in more personal news
last week was my daughter's birthday and
as is the case with every birthday AFC
Wimbledon sent her a card signed by a
bunch of players and most adorably there
was a long letter in it that was really
really thoughtful about how great a
season it's been as I read the letter to
Alice she was of course just enraptured
by it but my favorite part of the letter
was when they were like so we're in the
play-off final I waited as long as I
could to send this letter but in order
for it to arrive by your birthday I had
to send it before I found out what
happened so hopefully we won but every
member of the Dons Junior trust which it
by the way it only costs 10 pounds per
year and you get a birthday card signed
by the players so that's like 18 dollars
or something every member of the Dons
Junior trust gets a birthday card and
you can also join the trust if you want
the Don's trust org if you want to
become a member of a an owner of AFC
Wimbledon like me and Hank against his
will and my children and my wife and
Hanks wife against her will you can
become a member of the Dons trust at the
Don's trust dot org for adults that is
people over the age of 16 or actually
people at the age of 21 it's 25 pounds
per year so around 42 dollars and I'll
tell you what it's the best 42 dollars
you'll ever spend it's an amazing
organization it's so fun to be a part of
it and yeah I want to encourage people
to become owners of AFC Wimbledon all
right
thank you John we have one note before
we get to what we learned today from
Katie who says I am a former pizzeria
employee hoping to solve the slice
versus pizza peace debate all slices of
pizza all slices are pieces of pizza but
not all pieces are slices a slice refers
to a individually purchased piece of
pizza if you would like to get a whole
pie a cut off of that would be referred
to a peace hope that clears things up
thanks for all of the work you do I
don't know I'm not convinced I don't
know I'm not sold I'm not a hundred
percent sold on that although I am NOT a
former
pizzeria employees so Katy has more
authority on this topic than I do
no great so what did we learn today John
well we learned that there are a bunch
of people who want to die on Mars but
who probably won't
we learned that it would be a total
bummer like a super bummer to know how
the human story ends because it would
mean that you were the last human so
that's actually worse you know it's
funny when you phrase it that way I
don't actually seem that optimistic we
learned that when you're fighting but
don't have an opponent you're actually
just dancing just weird bad dancing and
of course we learned that if you were in
the bathroom and someone would like to
be in the bathroom you are in John would
like you to just shout out to ocupado
ocupado the thing happened just a sec
not though not just a sec just those
onthe nope don't make false promises if
anything maybe you should just under
promise so you can just say like just 12
minutes you should probably come out
three minutes later they'll be like what
a wonderful turn of events you should
probably go next door to a different
restaurant
alright God thank you for being on a
podcast with me it's always a pleasure
oh it's that's fun for me as well our
podcast is edited by Nicholas Jenkins
Claudia Morales is our intern we get
help with questions from rosianna halse
rojas our theme music is by gonna roll
it you can email us your questions
concerns or complaints at Hank and John
at gmail.com
or you can just go to the Twitter where
I am John Green Hank is Hank green you
can use the hashtag dear Hank and John
you could also follow us on our
preferred social media snapchat where
Hank is Hank gr II and I am John Green
snaps I'm great need us just take a naps
thank you everybody and as they say in
our hometown don't forget to be awesome
you
[Music]